the eu this vaccine has proven to be
highly effective
it prevents severe disease and
hospitalization
and it is saving lives vaccination
is extremely important in helping us in
the fight against covet 19 and we need
to use the vaccines we have
to protect us from the devastating
effects
the prague after a very in-depth
analysis has concluded
that the reported cases of unusual
blood clotting following vaccination
with the astrazeneca vaccine
should be listed as possible side
effects of the vaccine
as we communicated last week we convened
an
ad hoc expert group composed of experts
from a range of medical specialities
including
hematologists neurologists
epidemiologists and virologists
based on the current available evidence
specific risk factors such as age
gender or previous medical history of
of clotting disorders have not been able
to be confirmed as the rarest end
events are seen in all ages and in men
and women
a plausible explanation for these rare
side events
is that is an immune response to the
vaccine
leading to a condition similar to one
seen
sometimes in patients treated with
heparin it's called heparin-induced
thrombocytopenia
and dr strauss will give us more details
from the assessments
ema is working very closely with the
national competence authorities in all
the eu member states
and the company to make sure that these
risks are proactively communicated
to healthcare professionals it's
important
that both vaccinated people and
healthcare professionals are aware of
the signs and symptoms of these unusual
blood clotting disorders
so that they can be spotted quickly to
minimize any possible risks
we will continue to monitor the
scientific
evidence available on both effectiveness
and safety of all the authorized covet
19 vaccines
and we will issue further
recommendations if necessary on the
grounds of science and robust
evidence this case clearly demonstrates
one of the challenges
posed by large-scale vaccination
campaigns
when millions of people receive these
vaccines very rare events can occur that
were not identified during the clinical
trials
the role of pharmacovigilance the
monitoring of these side effects
is to help us to rapidly detect and
analyze these risks
and their impact on the benefit risk
profile of the vaccine
this case also shows us that our
pharmacovigilance system is working
these very rare and unusual events have
been picked up
identified analyzed and have allowed us
to come to science-based recommendations
to allow the safe and effective use of
this vaccine
ema scientific assessment will continue
to to work on all recommendations around
this vaccine
any national decision on the optimal use
in vaccination campaigns
will also take into account the pandemic
situation in
any individual country and other factors
such as hospitalization and
availability of vaccines so thank you
very much for joining us today and i'm
now very pleased to hand over to the
chair of our pharmacal vigilance and
risk assessment committee
dr samina strauss
thank you very much ms cook and good
afternoon
over the past few weeks the
pharmacovigilance risk assessment
committee
prac that i chair has analyzed reports
of blood clots
and people who received the covit 19
vaccine
astrazeneca as ms cook said the proc
has confirmed that overall the benefits
of the vaccine from
astaxineca and preventing covet 19
are well established and the risks are
very rare
the proc has conducted a very thorough
review of the reports
of rare and unusual blood clotting
events
in combination with slow plot low blood
platelets
with the help of an actual ad hoc expert
group
that looked at the data in greek great
detail
the committee has carried out a detailed
review
of the 62 cases of cerebral venous
sinus thrombosis and 24 cases of
splencic
vein thrombosis in the european union
drug safety database yoda vigilance
as of march 22
and 18 of these cases of these cases
were fatal
the cases came mainly from reporting
systems
of the european economic area and the uk
i can provide you also with more recent
figures
as of april 20 april 4
2021 the eu drug safety database had
received a total of 169 cases
of cvst and 53 of splanchic ventrombosis
and at that moment 34 million people
were vaccinated
in the european economic area and the uk
the more recent data did not change any
of the prague
recommendations after extensive
discussions
within the committee and taking into
account the findings of the expert group
our conclusion is that these clotting
disorders
are very rare side effects of the
vaccine
this conclusion is based on the detailed
clinical
mechanistic and epidemiological
assessments
including a distinct clinical pattern
immunological findings
and observation of more reported cases
than would be expected
from the background rates of these
unusual
conditions
the currently available data did not
allow us to identify
a definite cause for these complications
however plausible plausible explanations
have been put forward
including an immune response that leads
to a condition
that seems similar to an atypical
heparin induced thrombocytopenia
hit we're going to leave that
uh conference in amsterdam there for a
moment
just to update you with some lines that
we're getting
as to what we can expect to be hearing
from the uk
medicines regulator we are it's being
reported
that those under 30 are going to be
recommended that they should be offered
pfizer or moderna instead of
astrazeneca the mhra is expected to say
they're still huge benefits
of the vaccine in preventing covid19 and
serious disease but a differentiated
approach
looks like it's going to be recommended
by the regulator for those people who
are under the age of 30. we can go back
now to sky
science correspondent thomas moore who
has been
listening in many calls thomas for
some sort of risk mitigated approach it
looks like that's what we might be
hearing
from the mhra shortly
yes it all comes down to risk and
bennett benefit now clearly
older people are at much higher risk of
dying from covid for them
they can take the risk of of a blood
clot because it is still
extremely rare just four in a million or
so
so the risk of covid is much much higher
but of course younger people those in
their twenties the risks of dying
are very low indeed and that is why
the jcvi the joint committee on
vaccination
and immunization has taken the view that
for
people aged between 18 and 29
that they should be offered an
alternative vaccine
uh either pfizer or the moderna vaccine
now being rolled out in
wales from today and elsewhere in the uk
and in the coming weeks
there are going to be several million
doses of those so they will be offered
an alternative because so far there is
no safety signal
associated with those rna vaccines it's
a different kind of technology
to the oxford astrazeneca one and that's
why they're taking the precautionary
approach and for these young people
where their benefits of vaccination are
lower
that they also have to reduce the risk
and that means giving these alternative
vaccines
not astrazeneca what do we know
thomas you were just talking about the
talking there about the number of
vaccines we've got the different types
of vaccine we had moderna coming on
stream today
we have been warned that there's going
to be disruption in supply to
the vaccine program this month that
cohort that we're talking about
the bulk of which won't expect to be
seeing their first jabs
until towards the summer what do we
think it could mean
for the progress of the vaccine program
well certainly there's potential that it
will be delayed by a few
weeks and yes these people in their 20s
would have been
the last to receive the vaccinations
because
we're still going down the age bands uh
over
over the weeks now there's nobody due to
receive their first doses uh in
in april because there's already been a
supply issue
uh with the vaccines but things will
pick up again from may and begin to be
rolled out but you can expect that
the government's uh target of reaching
everybody by the end of july may now
have to be pushed back in
into august uh if there is is a problem
now
they will i'm sure say that as long as
all the pharmaceutical companies
are able to deliver their doses on time
then then they should be okay because
there will be
other vaccines due to come on stream not
least the the one from
johnson and johnson which is a single
dose but also one from novartis
so the medicine cabinet of vaccinations
is going to increase and that will
help uh certainly to get over this uh
this
problem that that does seem to be
emerging with the astrazeneca jab
what about people who are in that cohort
thomas who may have already had the
first
dose of an astrazeneca vaccine what then
happens
so the thinking is that they should and
we will hear the details
in the news briefing shortly that they
should come
forward still and have their second dose
now
whether they would uh in the
circumstances particularly when people
of a similar age who've yet to have
their first dose of being told that they
should be given alternative that will be
a real test of confidence in
in the vaccine but the medical regulator
and
and the vaccine experts for the
government do believe that there is
still
good benefit from this vaccine there is
no doubt that
older people should still have the
astrozenica vaccine
if there are lots of doses available
take them because the risk of
covid are so much higher the question is
for these younger people and i think we
need to be very careful
that we we stress that it is in the
young where the risk perhaps
begins to look a little bit uh difficult
to take
given the the benefits of the
vaccination because people don't
in their 20s don't generally die from
the vaccine if they're otherwise
from the the virus unless they have an
underlying health condition
they're only being asked to take it to
stop the spread of the virus to the
general population
now that risk trade-off certainly
becomes
very uh poignant doesn't it when you
think about it like that for the people
in the younger cohorts
what we were hearing from the ema there
was that they hadn't yet
identified any particular risk factor
associated with gender or
with age so are we just to presume that
the investigations are still ongoing and
this is really just a precaution
it is a precaution and they don't really
understand what's going on
they have found some evidence of
antibodies in the blood that are
associated with
other clotting disorders now is that an
immunological
consequence of vaccination we don't know
but it is a possible
uh causative link with the vaccine and
that's why
people are being extremely cautious and
certainly we've heard from the german
authorities
uh that there is this association uh
with young
women and as a precaution they the
french the germans they've all
and the canadians rather they've all
taken the view that
uh just to be sure just to be safe uh
they are not going to give the
astrazeneca people even to the the
middle age now here in the uk the
decision has been
uh to set the bar at a lower age band at
the age of 30. so
that is it is definitely a split
if you like uh within europe on on the
evidence
and just what action they need to take
none of this
thomas there is going to help confidence
is it in
in vaccines particularly in europe where
hesitancy is a bigger problem
i think this is going to be a big test
because as you say on the continent
there's always been already been a big
dip in in all vaccines but particular
the astrazeneca vaccine here in the uk
uh confidence in in the astrazeneca
vaccine has held up
people do believe that this is a good
british vaccine and
for for older people there is no doubt
that it certainly is
i think what people will be now asking
themselves is
i need to cut you off there we are just
seeing this press conference getting
underway at the department of health
let's listen in
we're just waiting for this press
conference to get underway we can see
the various figures who we've come to
know through this pandemic
uh assembled there we have dr june rain
chief executive of the mhra
professor jonathan van tan as well
deputy team
deputy chief medical officer
and this is a clinical
and scientific briefing
i'm joined today on my right by
professor wei shen lim chair of the
joint committee on vaccination and
immunisation the jcvi
to my immediate left by professor rain
chief executive officer of the mhra
and to my extreme left by professor
munir pier mohammed who is chair of the
commission on human medicines so today's
briefing
is about the uk vaccine program
in particular it is about the az
vaccine and we will explain
as we go through about a change of
course a course correction if you like
to the uk programme
now if you could have said to me back in
march 2020 and predicted how far we
would have come
so far with our vaccine program then
i'm not sure i would have believed that
we would have
got as far as we have the uk vaccine
program has been
the most enormous success indeed
and if you said to me that by march 2021
we would not have needed a course
correction
that also would have amazed me so
we must keep this in context of the
enormous success that we've
achieved so far i'm going to stop there
for now
and allow professor rayne to open
the briefing by explaining
her perspective from the mhra on where
we are arriving at today
professor thank you professor vantam i
will now update
on mhra's rigorous scientific review
of safety reports of very rare and
specific blood clots
with low platelet count thrombocytopenia
associated with covid19 vaccine
astrazeneca
over 20 million doses of the az vaccine
have been given
in the uk and we know that vaccines are
the best way
to protect people from covid 19 and have
already
saved thousands of lives and in fact
around six thousand
modeled in the uk by the end of february
but no effective medicine or vaccine is
without
risk and with vaccines more complex than
usual because the benefits
can be to people other than the
individual taking the vaccine
while the clinical trials of vaccines
allow us to assess
relatively common effects very rare
effects are only detected when a vaccine
is used at scale
on a large enough number of people and
that is why the uk
has careful monitoring systems in place
and these monitoring systems
are now detecting a potential side
effect of the covid19 vaccine
astra zenica in an extremely small
number of people the evidence is firming
up
and our review has concluded that while
it's a strong possibility more work
is needed to establish beyond all doubt
that the vaccine has caused these side
effects
our role is to continually monitor
safety during widespread use to confirm
that the vaccines are
performing as expected to identify any
very rare side effects
and to ensure the benefits outweigh the
risks
the public's safety is at the forefront
of our minds our teams of safety experts
scientists clinicians and
epidemiologists
have investigated reviewed and evaluated
thoroughly and scientifically
all safety reports and our safety
reviews are carried out in tandem
with the vaccination program we've
gathered a large amount of data
on the safety profile of the available
vaccines and we've done a rigorous
scientific review
of all the available data with regards
to suspected blood clots
with low platelet count the commission
on human medicines expert working group
has also met frequently and critically
accessed
all the data alongside our regulatory
review
and this has also included lay
representatives and advice from leading
hematologists based on the current
evidence
the benefits of the covid19 vaccine
astrazeneca against covid19
and its associated risks hospitalization
and death continues to outweigh the
risks
for the vast majority of people
our review has reinforced that the risk
of this rare suspected side effect
remains extremely small by the 31st of
march
over 20 million doses having been given
we have had
79 case reports up to and including that
date
31st of march all 79 cases
occurred after the first dose of these
79 cases
19 people have sadly died
these cases occurred in 51 women and 28
men aged from 18 to 79 years
and from these reports the risk of this
type of rare blood clot is about four
people in a million
who received the vaccine three out of
the 19
were under 30 years 14 of the 19 were of
the
cerebral venous sinus thrombosis with
low platelets
and 5 were other kinds of thrombosis in
major veins
the balance of benefits and risks is
very favorable
for older people but it is more finely
balanced
for the younger people and we at the
mhra
are advising that this evolving evidence
should be taken into account
when considering how the vaccine is used
today we'll be communicating information
and advice to health care professionals
on how to minimize risks and this will
provide a lot of guidance
including how to report any suspected
cases
the information for health care
professionals will be updated
and there will also be information for
the public things to look out for as we
continue to monitor this
issue anyone who has symptoms four days
after vaccination or more should seek
prompt medical advice a new onset of a
severe or persistent headache
or blurred vision shortness of breath
chest pain
leg swelling persistent abdominal pain
or
indeed unusual skin bruising or pinpoint
spots beyond the injection site so
professor simoneau will outline the
commission on human medicines further
advice
but i'd like to reiterate again that
this
is extremely rare
and with the proven effectiveness
against the disease that is still
a huge risk to our population the
balance of benefits
and known risks of the vaccine is still
very favorable for the vast majority of
people
so professor simonier over to you thank
you very much june
uh so i worked with the commission on
human medicines and the expert working
group
separately to thoroughly review all the
cases
coming in with the oxford astrozenica
vaccine
in the uk we've taken into account a
wide range
of data sources we've looked at
information about
usage of the vaccine various age groups
and
updated incidence rates and benefit risk
comparisons
for different populations by age and
gender
over the last couple of weeks the two
committees have spent almost 24 hours
in committee reviewing these reports
each report has been carefully
scrutinized by the mhra and by the
members of the working group
and further information has been
obtained where necessary
we've also had independent adjudication
of these cases by an expert hematologist
and we worked with another group of
hematologists
to develop a case definition of these
events
to make sure that the cases were
identified throughout the uk
and reported via the yellow card scheme
based on the currently available data
the commissioner medicines advising the
following
first our pregnant woman should continue
to discuss with the healthcare
professional
whether the benefits of having the
vaccine outweigh
the risks for them number two
people with a history of blood disorders
that increase the risk of clotting
should only have the covid19
vaccinations
when the benefits outweigh any potential
risks
number three anyone who experienced
cerebral or other major blood clots
occurring together with low levels of
platelets
after the first vaccine of courage 19
astrazeneca should not have the second
dose
we will be continually monitoring uh
further reports as they come in
and continuing monitoring other aspects
to identify
risk factors so that we can refine
the advice that we give at present
the data on people who've had two doses
of the covered 19 astrozenica vaccine
are limited
because these events are rare and
comparatively small number
of second doses have been given
therefore it is not possible to draw a
conclusion
about how frequently blood clots with a
low platelet count
happen following a second dose of the
vaccine but this will be monitored
closely by the mhra and by the chm
as part of the ongoing review
so just to put into context these events
are extremely rare
as june has already mentioned and i want
to put into context
in relation to covid 19 itself it is
important to remember the covet 19
itself
causes uh clotting and it causes lowered
platelets and i've got a few figures
from a paper which is recently
published pulmonary embolus clots on the
lungs
occurring 7.8 percent of people who have
covered 19.
dvt deep venous thrombosis clots in the
legs occurring 11.2 percent
uh who've had covert 19. and
of those people who have been infected
with sars covey ii getting curved 19
and ending up in itu 23
will have some form of clot
covered 19 also causes strokes in about
1.6 percent
and up to 30 percent of people who
develop covert 19
i will get thrombocytopenia which is
lowering of the platelet count
and that puts into context that the risk
of clots
and lowered platelet is much higher with
covert 19 than these extremely rare
events which are occurring
with a vaccine so to finish off the chm
is advised that the link between the
vaccine and blood clots
in the cerebral and other veins
occurring together with lowered
platelets
is getting firmer but absolute proof of
the link between the vaccine and adverse
vents
will need extensive scientific work
based on the currently available
evidence and the benefit risk remains
favorable
for the vast majority people but as june
said is more finely balanced
for the younger people and we are
advising that this evolving evidence
should be taken into account when
considering the use of the vaccine
i'll hand back to professor van tan
thank you professor serbaneer thank you
professor brain
you've now heard from the regulatory
experts
and in a moment i will turn to the new
advice
from the jcvi with professor lim
but before we do that i'd like to put
into context
in a visual way what the data are
telling us
in terms of benefits and risks so if i
could
have the first slide please
so this slide and i'll go through the
first one
slowly shows you in blue type to the
left of the slide
the potential benefits from covid19
vaccination
and on the orange part to the right the
potential
harms and you can see that as you go
down the slide from top to bottom
those benefits and potential harms
are arrayed by age band starting at 20
to 29
young adults through to 60 to 69
relatively old adults and
the way these data have been arrayed
are in terms of intensive care
admissions prevented via vaccine
on the left and serious harms
potentially due to the vaccine
on the right and i thank colleagues at
the
winton center for risk risk and evidence
communication
at cambridge university for help with
getting this slide together
and this first slide is set as you can
see from the title
in a scenario of low
exposure and in actual fact the rates of
disease assumed in this scenario
are lower than those we currently have
in the uk
at the moment and you can see
that if you look at the 20 to 29 age
band
then the potential benefits um amount to
0.8 icu admissions averted
compared with serious harms of
potentially 1.1
but as you go up through the age groups
the amount of serious harm
declines but the amount of benefit in
terms of averted
icu admissions becomes much more
pronounced
and these are arrayed over a 16 week
period
now we don't expect vaccine to last
for 16 weeks we very
confidently expect that it is going to
be many many months of protection
from a vaccine and the reason for using
16 weeks
is is because that is a typical pandemic
wave that's the duration of it
but you can see that um
at a very low exposure risk lower than
we have in the uk at the moment
the risk benefit is relatively finely
balanced in those
younger age groups but it becomes very
overwhelming
in favor of vaccine as you go down the
up the ages
if we go on to the next slide please
this is now a medium risk scenario
and it is um set at um 60 cases
per 100 000 that is marginally like
higher than the uk average at the moment
but it is lower than some of the
remaining
hot spots in the uk and you can see that
when you
when the disease is around us more when
there's more exposure
then the benefits the potential benefits
start to stack up but the potential
serious harms
remain static of course and this is
still over a 16
week period and you can see that the
data become
more overwhelming in terms of vaccine
benefit
finally let's move to a high exposure
risk
and this one next slide please
is set typically at where we get to
in terms of a pandemic wave this is set
at the height
of the second pandemic wave that we went
through
in the last few months and i think is
reflective of the kind of
um scenario we want to avoid
in the forthcoming autumn and winter if
we possibly can
but here when there's a lot of covert 19
circulating in the population
you can see that even in the 20 to 29
group the potential benefits in terms of
intensive care
admissions averted is very much higher
than the serious harms due to vaccine
and
and that's why the regulators
have concluded as they have about
risk benefit for the astrazeneca vaccine
so i hope that's placed it all into a
bit of context for everybody
so that um i recognize it's been a
detailed scientific
discussion so far but hopefully those
figures bring it to life
and at this point i'm going to hand over
to professor lim
to um give us the jcvi advice
thank you thank you jonathan
jcbi has been meeting over the last two
weeks
and we have carefully and independently
reviewed
the safety evidence and the benefit
evidence
given to us from mhra and public health
england
and that includes some of the kinds of
data that you've seen
earlier on the slide we are well aware
of the
high level of protection that covet 19
vaccines
provide particularly against serious
disease that is hospitalization
it admission and from dying from corbett
19 disease
against that must be balanced the
uncertain occurrence of
an extremely rare adverse events that
may be associated with vaccination
acting really in the interest of safety
and for public benefit
jcvi feel that there are three points of
advice that we would like to put across
the first is that information given to
individuals
while being offered vaccination and
information given to health
professionals
should be appropriately updated to
reflect the latest
considerations and deliberations by jcvi
and by mhra the second point
is that those who have received their
first dose of astrazeneca vaccine
should continue to be offered the second
dose of estrogenical vaccine according
to the set schedule
and the final bit of advice is that
adults who are aged
18 to 29 years old who do not have
an underlying health condition that puts
them at higher risk
from serious coveting disease should be
offered
an alternative 19 vaccine in preference
to the astrazeneca vaccine
where such an alternative vaccine is
available
and perhaps it's useful to state what is
not
advised as well we are not advising
a stop to any vaccination for
any individual in any age group we are
advising a preference
for one vaccine over another vaccine
for a particular age group really
out of the utmost caution rather than
because we have
any serious safety concerns
this will obviously have some
implications
in terms of operation and deployment of
vaccines
and i'm just going to hand back
therefore to jonathan to set those out
for us thank you shen so
um i'm going to um round off the last
part of this briefing now
and um people out there listening to
this will say
well what does this mean for me and what
should i now do so um let me begin with
the deployment
piece um this is a change in clinical
advice
for the under 30s it will require
some changes in the way that the
national health service
operationalizes the vaccine rollout
program
but i have spoken to my colleagues in
the nhs in some detail this morning
and i am assured that actually
because of our supply situation in
relation to alternative vaccines
the effect on the timing of our overall
program
should be zero or negligible that of
course
is contingent upon getting the supplies
that we expect to get of the alternative
vaccines which are the pfizer vaccine
currently in use
and the moderna vaccine that we hope to
bring into deployment from mid-april in
england
so that's the kind of what does it mean
um
for me on the what should i do then
um please be reassured
that two sets of independent experts on
the regulatory side
the mhra and the chm
and on the clinical advice side the jcvi
are all over this and i can testify to
the many
many hours of work they have been
putting into
getting this advice to you in the um
last week or so really almost working
without a break
and my thanks to the members of those
various committees and
organizations who've worked honestly
night and day behind the scenes to
get to this point this is a course
correction there's no question about
that but it is
um in a sense in medicine quite normal
for physicians to alter their
preferences for how patients are treated
over time it's happened with vaccines
um only a few years ago up until a few
years ago the advice
to the elderly and flu vaccines was get
your vaccine
and then the jcvi then changed its
advice
and said our preference is now for the
adjuvanted vaccine
for the elderly so changes in preference
for vaccines
are business as usual and this is
a course correction but this is a kind
of massive
beast that we are um driving along at
enormous pace with enormous success
this vaccine program and you know if you
sail a massive liner across the atlantic
then it's not really reasonable that you
aren't going to have to make at least
one course correction
during that voyage and i frame this very
much in
those terms the nhs has a message
that we will get the right vaccine to
you
in the right time according to the new
jcvi advice
there might be a small delay sometimes
there might be a slightly greater
distance that some people are asked to
travel
but the nhs is all over this and
understands the challenge
of making the advice from jcvi
truly operational in a smooth way
so i'm going to sum up there
by saying this is a course change
it is based on a clinical preference
based on newly emerging data it will be
kept under
very careful review please remember
that the benefits of vaccine accrue
over a very long period of time we are
fairly confident that it's months and
months
whereas the the
the event of vaccination is a a brief
moment
vaccines continue to be the way out for
the uk
they continue to be the way in which we
can get our lives
back to normal and our economy opened up
again
in the shortest time possible thank you
very much for listening and we will now
take some questions
i think the first question is um from
fergus walsh at the bbc hello fergus
hi thank you very much indeed um can i
ask two questions
are you worried that this change of
course might
um damage vaccine confidence especially
in the young
be specific on on the risks are the
risks
to those from the vaccine in the under
30s
significantly higher than among older
age groups
thank you so on the first point
i will answer that question and
say that clearly this is a course
change we don't want it to result in a
loss of vaccine confidence
i hope i've reassured you that these are
really carefully considered decisions
and it remains vitally important
that people who are called back for
their second dose
come for it and it remains vitally
important
that all adults in the uk come forward
for vaccination
when they are offered it on the point
about
risk i think i will refer to professor
lim
thank you the importance really is not
simply the risk to an individual
there is a slight gradation in the risk
of this serious adverse event occurring
in younger people compared to older
people
but it's really the benefit risk balance
which is most important here
and the benefit from vaccination is
as we know very very high in older
people
and decreases as age goes down because
the risks from covet 19
goes down with age but there is still a
benefit
to younger people from being vaccinated
and overall that benefit is still in
favor of being vaccinated
it happens that where we have an
alternative vaccine
we feel on balance it would be
preferable
to offer the very youngest people who
have no other health conditions
the alternative vaccine instead of the
astrazeneca vaccine
really just on the side of safety rather
than because of any
particular significant concern about the
risk from the vaccine itself
yeah thank you fergus i think i just add
that the
slides that i showed to you um
were based on icu admissions and didn't
take into account the additional
benefits of vaccine in terms of
preventing
long covid which we know is quite a
significant problem
after this illness the costs of the
illness itself
and the costs of potentially passing on
the infection to family and friends
thank you tom clark itv
hello thank you um can i come back to
the vaccine confidence
uh question you you've obviously laid
out very clearly what the risk benefit
profile are to reassure people what the
risks are facing are however what would
you advise
somebody who is say 31 years of age
a family member a loved one i don't know
who's been encouraged to take the
astrozenica vaccine what would you tell
them
in terms of the risks that they might be
taking on and the benefits
the vaccine might bring
that's uh that's a very good question
and in fact we were just discussing that
earlier
uh because we know somebody uh whose
daughter is
around 30 31 and that is a very relevant
and important question
one of the really fundamental things
about the vaccine program is that it's
shown to be fair
and it's transparent and that's
precisely why we want to have
this briefing now to demonstrate what
the risks and the benefits are so that
everybody is informed
before they come for your vaccination
and we have set up quite clearly
what the benefits are against the risk
and why we've made a decision about the
30 year old
and who is healthy and otherwise
well for somebody who's 31 and
32 i think they have to make their own
decision as to what they want to do
about vaccination
we would still say that the balance is
in favor of being vaccinated
because of the risks from covet 19 and
the protection that the vaccine offers
[Music]
looking at your table there to explain
the risks um it
appeared to me that the risk of someone
below 29 was five and a half times
higher of this
very rare blood clotting events than
someone 60 to 69.
um is that what you've seen in the data
there is a definite trend towards a
higher risk of blood clots
in younger age groups and what questions
does that raise
for i don't know pediatric vaccination
campaigns
indeed i wonder indeed i wonder whether
in a moment um seven year want to come
back
and just discuss the um
the wrist signal from the ages
in terms of trouble cytopenia and blood
clots
but in terms of moving into pediatric
vaccination jcpi has not made any firm
decision yet
on when to move into vaccination for
children the clinical trials are still
ongoing
regarding the safety of vaccines in
children so
no decision made on that point yet
thank you thank you so tom in in passing
the baton back to um professor sir
meniere
um on on the numbers um i i will in
this passing through me as it were um
say that
the jcbi's decision um to give advice
for the under 30s was taken
you know fully cognizant of the fact
that their advice would
therefore apply above the age of 30 to
31 year olds and and that was part of
the
consideration and um we are
talking here in the context of extremely
small numbers
by age and that makes the data very
difficult to interpret
but i'm sure so many will elaborate much
better on this
thank you so so there is um
a slightly higher risk uh in the younger
age group
uh compared to the old age group and
obviously as has been already said
that we do need to look at the relative
benefits versus the risks
in different age groups the reason why
uh the it's a higher risk in the young
age group
is not clear as i said earlier we need
to undertake
much more scientific work to understand
why
this of link between the vaccine and
particularly younger age group is
occurring
and that will help us in the future to
be able to
then refine the advice that we give in
terms of product information
further work needs to be done on all of
that with regard to the children
um there's of the trial
has been paused by the data safety
monitoring board
for an abundance of caution really we
know the children
are at much lower risk of these clots
and so on and as we
are able to accumulate more data over
the next few weeks
the mhra and and the expert working
groups will be liaising
with the trial is set to oxford um and
then to be able to determine
whether the trial can uh start again uh
based on the data that's available
thank you thank you tom um on children i
will just add that there are multiple
manufacturers
with different types of vaccines all
working
to do trials in children and so
um you know this is not the only um show
in town
in terms of trying to um establish
um whether a vaccine can be authorized
and suitable for children
that's an unfolding story that we'll
have to leave to another day
another tom now tom moore from sky
presented this as a choice between the
astrazeneca vaccine
and having covid but that's not true at
any age
that if you've recognized the young
could be given an
alternative vaccine then why not the
middle age too
and can i also ask in europe and canada
there are countries that have decided
not to give the astrovax astrozenica
vaccine to anybody under the age of 55
or 60. are they being too cautious
would you like to begin on that sure
thank you um
every country has to make their own
decision
regarding what is best for their own
population
and that takes into account the kind of
disease that we have in our country
the size of the wave the risk of a next
wave occurring
the amount of vaccines we have how well
the vaccine program is
being delivered and obviously
the values of our own people
whether we want to accept the vaccine or
not so i believe that every country will
in the end have to make their own
decision
regarding the risk and benefit just as
an example
it's sad to say but true that in some
countries life expectancy is not as good
as it is in the uk
and people may live to a mean age of
about 50.
and for them is their life expectancy
will mean that their risk
benefit in terms of when to draw the
line against a particular vaccine
maybe any of the vaccines that are
available
will be different from another country
where life expectancy may be different
and so it's taking all of these things
into account that we've come to a
decision
in the uk given our vaccine availability
our supply the kind of pandemic that
we're having
the b117 variant that we've had
all of these together we felt that the
correct judgment
was that it is around the 30-year
threshold where there are younger people
who do not have any health conditions
where we would offer
the alternative vaccine rather than
saying
everybody in the country should be
offered an alternative vaccine because
really
this is an extremely rare adverse event
we do not know for sure that it's
related to one vaccine
or not yet it may also be relevant
to some other vaccine it may not even be
related to a vaccine
it may be related to covet itself we're
just
unsure and the advice we're giving is
really based
very much on protecting the population
and working on the principle that safety
is uh
our biggest concern so thank you
tom i'm going to reinforce the point
about context
um and weishan has kind of stolen the
example about um
a a low a low-income country where sadly
life expectancy is not the same as the
uk
and the context of risk and benefit is
going to be very different in each
population
and the jcvi was entirely free
to make its own advice and
recommendation to us
as it saw fit that has always been the
way with jcvi
they are always independent and they can
say and do
as they wish that having been said if
you look at
um some of my slides and if you look for
example at the high
exposure risk category then
um you know the idea of
withholding a vaccine where a potential
harm for example in the 40 to 49
group is 0.5
harms per 100 000 people versus
51.5 intensive care
admissions averted and that's not taking
into account
hospitalizations long covered and
spreading to others
then the notion that you would clip a
vaccine at that point is
pretty absurd really and so you know
it is very much an independent decision
but uh
i think it's been taken in an extremely
rational way
doses of other vaccines
no it isn't it absolutely wasn't
and as i've explained to
to to you all the program
should not be delayed because of this
changing course
everything should stay on course
thank you right we'll now turn to um
nick mcdermott
at the sun that's taking my question um
both um someone near and dr rain talked
about
the the link between um the
astrazeneca jab and these blood clots
the language before was pretty vague we
were unsure and
they both said that the link is now
firming up
so for the avoidance of doubt um on the
balance of probabilities do we now think
scientifically the data suggests
that more likely than not there is a
link by a more than 50
probability there is a link between this
jab and these rare blood clots
and a second question maybe professor
lim or professor van tam
we are expecting the um yanson one shot
jab to arrive in the summer
and um we're saying that the under 30s
will be prioritized for alternative jabs
so is there potentially potentially a
good news story for
younger people who may actually get the
one shot jab or prioritize for it
and therefore more likely to get um
international vaccine passports and go
on holiday sooner
because they don't need to wait for that
12-week second job
thank you thank you nick i'm
i will pass the first part of the
question to my regulatory colleagues i'm
not sure
who wants to go first on that one the
important question
of how firm is the evidence yes the
evidence has accrued
not only in numbers and kinds of cases
but the pattern of those cases so we
feel it's a much more solid basis in our
regulatory work
world to put in the side effect
into our product information and that
tells us that it's a
reasonably plausible link
but there needs to be much more work on
the scientific
understanding of this new constellation
of symptoms
to give us that feeling of the proof
that that you would expect
and that work will go on at pace and i
would like to
hand to someone ear to tell you more
about that yeah so the early evidence
suggests
that this constellation of symptoms
is caused by an immune response
against platelets which allows the
platelets to
then lead to clotting in different parts
of the body but what we don't have
clearly is the link between the vaccine
and how
the immune response becomes activated
against the platelets and that's where
the
scientific work needs to go on to
identify what that link is
so that we can then develop ways and
strategies to be able to overcome
this adverse event for the future second
thank you now part of
your second part of your question nick
um about
other vaccines and in particular the um
the the yanson vaccine
um in terms of the immediately available
alternatives the immediately available
alternative
right now already in deployment in the
uk is the pfizer vaccine
we do expect to have quantities of
moderna
beginning to be deployed from mid-april
in england
and those those will be the two for the
next few weeks as it were
it's common knowledge and public
information
that the uk has placed orders with
janssen we do not yet have certainty on
the timing of delivery
but that vaccine could become available
over the summer
and is indeed a one-dosed
schedule therefore it must be part
in the frame if you like or in the mix
for
solutions for vaccine requirements
going forwards and indeed for the young
people
you referred to but that's you know
always been part of the uk
strategy to have you know multiple
horses in the race
so that we would always be in a good
position if we needed flexibility
to be able to exercise it but my final
cautionary point for you is that this
is a vanishingly rare
but sadly quite serious adverse event
but it is vanishingly rare
and you can't pick these kind of things
up until you have
literally deployed tens of millions of
doses of vaccine
and therefore for the vaccines not yet
deployed
in large numbers around the world we
have to wait and see
if we are going to see or not see
similar signals
and therefore it again reinforces the
message that it's important to have many
horses in this race
thank you we're going to tom whipple at
the times next thank you very much
um in terms of the mechanism um it'd be
great to explain if you could explain a
little bit more about your theories
about
how this might be triggered particularly
as uh
we've got several other indian virus
vector vaccines like the johnson johnson
like the sputnik one
um that presumably a mechanism that
causes this nest rezenica could be
likely to do so
in them too and as a second question
if we know this is a possible side
effect are the ways to then
mitigate it and make it safer for people
who
have it thank you tom thank you tom
that's
a a very mechanism-based question i'm
going to pass that straight to sermonia
uh thank you so um
the early evidence uh suggesting that
there is an immune response which is
occurring
in relation to uh
whatever the event is it may be the
vaccine or maybe a previous covered
infection for example
but the way that uh that immune response
then targets the
platelets and why targets are platelets
in the very
small number of individuals we are not
clear about and that further work
is ongoing at the moment i think it is
really important to understand the
mechanisms because it might provide us
with ways of being able to prevent this
in the future for example uh if you were
able to identify the mechanisms
you'll be able to refine the advice
that's given so we can actually identify
risk factors for example and then try to
prevent it in individuals who have those
risk factors
it may also allow us to be able to then
think about modified
modified vaccines which do not cause
this particular adverse event
in the future you mentioned the
adenoviral vector
and yes there are several vaccines with
adenoviral vectors
but we don't know whether it is related
to our novera vector or it is related to
something else at the moment and again
that's part of the scientific work that
needs to undergo at the moment
thank you we will now move
to um hannah giesler at the express
thank you for the briefing um the
majority of cases that have been
reported um were in women with a smaller
number in men
as you've said there's not a lot of data
yet because it's so rare but just
thinking about those potential
mechanisms that you mentioned
are there any kind of possible
biological reasons why women might be at
higher risk than men or is it just too
early to say that
and then secondly if i may the yellow
card scheme collects data on all sorts
of possible adverse
effects are there any others where
you've seen any hint of an increased
risk
or is that is this really the only one
thank you hannah i'm going to pass to
sir meniere
first of all um for the question about
women
and then to the yellow cards to uh
professor rain
thank you sure so of the 79 cases
51 were in women and 28 were in men
the numbers are quite small um and this
may
reflect um actually who's getting the
vaccine because many of the
healthcare workers for example are women
but if you actually look at the
incidence rate uh according to the
number of vaccines administered
there's actually no difference between
men and women so we will need to
continue to monitor this and see whether
there is a gender predilection
to developing this particular adverse
event but at the moment we do not have
any evidence to say that
either men or women are more likely to
get this
on the yellow card scheme every week we
publish
all the reports in summary form but also
the report
on a thursday talks about any trends
that have come
up so i really can't do any better than
encourage people to read it
but also to encourage everyone to report
to us
every report matters and every report
will be carefully looked at
thank you thank you hannah
so that brings us to the end of the
questions posed by
the media today i would like to um
conclude at this point
by thanking my colleagues for their time
and more importantly than their time
today for the
immense amount of hours and effort they
and their
assistants have put in behind the scenes
to get us to this point i want to
emphasize to everybody
that covid19 remains a serious illness
that unfortunately as professor witty
has said it is something we're going to
have to live with
in the long term vaccine is
likely to be and continue to be
extremely important
in this country in getting life back to
normal
we are managing this very carefully i
hope you've seen
real evidence today of authentic experts
looking after your interests doing the
very best
they can it is a course correction
but nevertheless it is full speed ahead
with the uk vaccine program so that we
can get life back to normal
thank you this briefing is concluded